identify the four solids shown below so
this one over here they haven't
specified it but for the sake of this
video we will assume that all of these
edges of this of this figure of this
object are all the same length so this
edge is equal to that edge is equal to
that edge is equal to that edge
all of these
are the same length and that they're all
at right angles to each other and if you
have something like this you have a cube
you have a cube a cube you essentially
have six faces that are all squares all
of the edges are all the same length and
they're all sitting at right angles
relative to the other edges so this
right over here we would call a cube the
most common or one of the most common
cubes that we see in our everyday life
are the dice that you would play with in
a in your standard board game now this
thing over here you have this round
base and then it points upwards it looks
a lot like something that you would put
ice cream in if you were to flip it over
so if you were to flip it over
you could put some you could put some
ice cream in it i'll draw some ice cream
so that's that's maybe we'll maybe we'll
do multiple flavors of ice cream you
could put ice cream in it and we would
call this
we would call this an ice cream cone
and so that's a big clue that this is
also
this is also a cone it's also the shape
of the hats that a gnome would wear or i
guess there's other types of cones that
we could think of a teepee is also a
cone
now let's think about this one right
over here you have a circular base so i
kind of assume that this thing is
transparent that you can see through it
so if it was made out of glass you could
see this bottom base if it wasn't you
wouldn't be able to see it and then it
has a circular top right over there
the most typical thing in our everyday
life that we see like this would be a
soda can or a soup can and so this is
called a cylinder
this is called a cylinder
cylinder you've probably heard the word
cylinder before in the context of cars
you might have a four-cylinder car or a
six-cylinder car and that's because the
actual chambers where the fuel is
exploded are shaped like this they are
cylinders and so a four-cylinder car in
its engine literally has four of these
cylinders where an explosion takes place
and that explosion actually pushes up a
piston and that's what actually drives
the car well that's not the point of
this video but that's why you people say
i have a four cylinder car or a six
cylinder car and eight cylinder car
whatever
and then finally we have this thing over
here we have a bunch of edges that are
all at right angles to each other and
every face here isn't necessarily a
square it looks more like every face
here is a rectangle and so this type of
thing that's ever it has a lot of the
properties of a cube
every every every uh every edge is at a
right angle to every other edge but
instead of every face necessarily being
a square every face over here is a
rectangle you call this a rectangular
prism
rectangular
prism now you might be saying well sal
isn't doesn't a cube meet all of your
constraints for a rectangular prism
because aren't squares also rectangles
and you would be right a this thing
right over here could also
be referred to as a rectangular prism
but calling it a cube also lets us know
that all of the faces are are are the
same they all are squares